cs у до 17 років у нас про святе нас
столітті наука спраги
перебував його так званому в монетарній
плоті і кей фінансово всякі петр йому
всі накиди вилазь а в принципі і за
дешевим принципам так потім
і шоу ж сара штаб порубав це 2 це 6
рубатимемо і
і у звареного пива квіти на мені перука у
мене про свято особливо sweet as рідня ,
адже національні спайки того що ми
вкладаємо в середньому свиту крученого на
цими на спинці яскраві мої сни будуть
чотири цього наскільки які з нами будуть
підручнику закласти цього треба жити в
принципі чим я буду мати державу і
заклали те я катя держава буду я думаю
що ми миємо вже 25 уроків та зведу які
дозволяють нам купувати їжу таких посилань
що найяскравіший шлюз вигляд і спливає на
ніг ідентичність людей на національну
ідентичність
на ідентичність зігнутих в принципі ці
люди сповідують
і на них не починаю розуміння критичне
осмислення слова мої будні цьому я думаю
що фінансово не я свято і вуса благо у
святі шпиль а й по паршиво але база
страшному а з бюджету ся вона важлива вище
і не важливо що саме моє фінансово ціле
світлі я думаю що ми так вже проходимо до
тому моменту колимі моїм набагато бігти
по ідеально підходить і думі ст у того шо
держава володіючи доброю і підручником я
кисть в 4 до 6 суеца ви ще квіти я
думаю що напиши завдання kia парадному та
страждати від мети повернення науки до почту
то ви ще й світи розділ вони вище
усвяти і науки мета спаду хтось
туризму цикли в університетах забирали
думки не завищуй повтори не
ви знаєте що святого наука розвивається
тільки на основі того, що вся наука
засрати ж нам університету
ми знаємо чому зарубався ми знаємо таке
що ж перервала ці у фінансово не так
нас я різанина то горе та фінансування
алло я думаю що стежка цифрі не ювт на
користь наук often і складна крученого до
н е і наука моя повернути осідаючих
початкових заплатимо щось відчувається
професіонал технічно святі в тому
залі дружини одноразового цао виривався і
фінансової за професійні
технічного квіти столітті
годину тут було знає як такі гарячі пари
пал усе нам, а голоси його перекинуті
знайте щоб щоб зачепа dbal
а ліцею ви дальність держави так спинози
грамотному та спину з регіоном та чоловікові та
ось так а ось з однієї кулі дальність
держави
ми фактично розрулював і провести ну
технічного свиту
на дані але моді та економістами юристом
в результаті за дуже давно я була harq
та виїжджають автомобілем з парку
овального майдані кабелю
залізничне у вокзалі вона про
повальному травні данчуку процідити 2
юристи то випускники та юридичної
академії ярослава мудрого томас чітко
укладається спочатку а юрій steel а
потім місяця
проц затишно парк овальному травень данчуку а
чоловіки з їх 2 і хлопчики від вид на
парк овальному майданчики можемо з них
була добрим у лери че штукатури чи
кисеньки уявляєте апельсинчик
професії для біржових дати їй держави
я думаю що мода чи година моди на юристі
віку на місці - і потрібного power that
is a до того що реального подругу і
я тремтіла хочеш сказати шоу важливі ви ми
я інвестицію методику
будь методику почту читає схоже і
чудовисько буквально повернулося в шарага
через центр маршала центр на чай на ту
до дуже гарно презентації мало генерал
американський світ албан watches & key
розповідав на скільки window пропалений
позитивно виражений слухач ми
курсантам та hour піскова взяти
авіаційного університету алло я просто
попросив нас зрубати шо щоб їх на
база the nike ви початися у налякана
моделей вийде студенти ви не but i
менших приміщеннях та матері in шум
база на та кевін годинник я думаю що ми
самі ця знаємо у алли я думаю що ти
такий же вид побачили їсти і
університеті так надії в джерела
хороший all я думаю блазня і приватні
кандидати на харчування через чекати їх
гаї і п'ють ремейк університети ви
простого ються на те, щоб государ по
паршивий цурався загину подругою ви
чого у совей студентам на 19 20 паршиво
стільці ти і тут уже ніхто не пройду його
треба допоможе церкві на трубі тієї кільки
і сам ректор і тільки самі люди і
приймають рішення про
qt вкладу ти січеш ти брат що я про
конана ми чому тут багату такого
набагато били петлю даєте без
посередництва метушитися проблема я
пропадаю нам такі парламент наш
ідеальності ми заслухаємо u2 головних
найважливішими заслухаємо кримінально додати
вид на неї міністра святі науки
понивіле гріна і ви читали будуть
будди в шкарпетки в dota
прошу заступника голови комент від usb
це навички його почту
панова ксандра співаківського далі
будуть дві
місяць так поведе і 20 haven спить до
поводження галону води 15
далі майбутнє 2 із заповідей вид паршиве
віце-президент національної академії
наук України та пішов заступника голови
коментатор України стане бюджету до 5
хвали далі пропан вулиця такі порядок
роботи і ми погода ви і я питаю
заступником голови комітету
народним депутатом видавить від 0 до 3х
років
новий сту тому що виймає доступ
дати їй трибуни на боготу частки та
найважливіших що дня я думав обожнювання та
і видно все і телеку але і народним
депутатом і будуть мати можна виступати і
до 5 млн все-таки іраном від нашої роботи
я дуже минулий вкладу тис outer
регламент за 30 holdings до завершення
увійшло години ви почуєте сигнал призначаєш
вас є 30 секунд щоб завершити і вашу
думка і щоб
адже за видами них приготувати цінний
учасник виступі
екшон є пара чим та киньте ми будемо
розуму ти з чаєм для ув'язнених виступивши
слова види міністра вас вигляд і та
великий заступник голови та комітету
вершина загортати підсумки ми переходимо
в нашу і роботи і я приймаю все
запиту you do слова міністра усвяти та
науки україни ваніллю рано бито добре
чи зрозуміли
винна поні голову
шановний учасника та парламентських
чутками в історії ваш до знає і вона love
трансформації якудза раз проживаючи
україна на вухах розпусти та процесу
кеди
енді відривав і бесід або теми розлучення
нації державу творіння формування в
відкритої економіки ціни просто
виду кидається в у свиті і науки а у
свято і наука малому ставити темп і ритм
меншим реформам, а ось для чого нам наше
завдання c справедливі фінансово не я у
свитою та наукою простіше допомагає подала
тендері вниз олег простіше може особливі
вокал та їх не дістати але по гребеню ватою
ціни ревнощі і цілі збуваються в свиті
там у
завдання розумні батоги і другові забезпечать
і перше повіяв аніони ревнощів там у
справедливо і фінансово не і про святі
нас яками танці такий раз ходив кішки
століття з забезпечити доступ шкіряні дітей
не дмуй окисні усвяти
місця проживання соціального статусу
матеріального стану, крім фізіології
бетін і в навчитися і принцип означаючи і
на ступні пак і кішки крадіжок їм
колективом у рамках пріоритету
височених державою вбито контролем
грамотності
ми буду йому європейські з успіхом
освітленого за голу
c suspect вояк з-за рубля та у польшу
чергу високу кваліфікацію про цію про
чуму шипиш важливий принцип
справедливості even пакла даної в
основу реформи у світою наукою я куми
розкачав та й частий ви вже у хвалених на
законі та tedx нормативно-правових актив
все кремом і фракцію ми сьогодні на прям
каймой будник змін можна по бачаті вже
за раз
поспішаю про свиту ви добкіна us with us
тримав нотами стиглих бюджетів України в Україні
продажів
а них 10 руки коли волосся в межах адже
5 до 7 цілих 30 400 500 до ВВП
у 2016 уроки була передача але 5s статевий
але й сотки ввп на свиту
у 2017 р. ми прогнозу йому зрощення
до 6 з половиною у сотки ввп на у
свиту
з формальної точки зору колір за видом та
практики європейських краєм однак
найважливіший аналіз стану показує в
україни щоб дотки в на світі видно
сина всі соціальні виплати для зубів
чого світи і ви дотки спеціального
фонду в кому з оклади не кішкою
що за свою економічну природу на і
бюджетними the movie дно з не показано
криві дотки в на свиту Україні нас
правдив шукай вид середніх доки знаки в по
європейських країн
важливі ось так вашому розумі ти розбудив ви
дотки в ніс виду за видам його почту
середня професій технічно ви ще душ
кельна післядипломної пузо шкільного
свято у хлопець вони з європейськими
державами у нас дешеві ділянки ви дотки
на вашу почет хлопець нянею середню і
the prophecy на технічну якимів я
пити сумкою руку насіння та
у продаж двох інших рук України
розгойдала політику децентралізації
c-moll вона сувоєм змішування чисткою ви
дотки в нам світлозара хотілося місцевих
бюджетів і ми знаємо загальна в цифру про
і кого гарячого в сірі дні розуму не собі
бюджет і дорослі на 49 сотки аліми
розумі майні цифра в сирі
правді в різьблених рамах рязанців розбивши
шині тілу руку ми ж шулай важко щи
з фінансово не їм професіонал
технічні свята і виносив із села дуже
багато уроки
за рахунок стабілізації та й тут ati
у ряду з резервних ресурсів ми до
чи фінансово систему прав тихо святі для
щоб стабілізацією вівці і критичний
Рік арешт 2017 раку за 2d професій на
технічного святим а йти перейти на
фінансування за блажь кількома на
приголосний бюджету та бюджету замість
обласних центрів через краще ним
субвенції нас дістали за хворі
середні про світи система середні почти
фінансується за рахунок у свиней
субвенції закріплених за місцевими
бюджетами ви дотки та на пружині ситуації
з виплатою ранку битні плати ми відривали
usher нього
у черні чеської області для закупівлі лише
пильних автобусі вид таких шкільних
автобусів закуплено
на 2 system і boot і на 200
проходять тендери
так само як і було виділено 200
мільйонів гривень на закупили обладнання
тривають їх завзятих shteel причину йоги
тайяки в шилась на індивідуальному
анапчани я тепер їх довозять у володіння
хорошої школи то в той усю практику
треба продовжу вати крутому вичитуванню збр
голки чоловіки без дітей пучкові школи на
в чат і сізо місцях я канай речі замісимо
проживання топну умовної
над і шовний на закриття шкіл анар і
на зниження щаблів загальної душа
мало школа для того ще де ти старших
класів малий рівні шанси потім продовжу
ось його свиту сам іван і
молодого запису до завзятих шкіль адже ви
видно і закону для вийшли у святу 2016
уроки проведено про розпад
державного замовлення нижче вищого та
початковим і за скарбом і вид по видно так
пріоритеті vip обожнюємо у ступ nike та у
цьому
колимугу турали в завалі розбудив
державного замовлення за спеціальностями
і був утворений авлос знайти простіше
вибори лопання голова про свій поступ
слові ж саме харчування
гній державного замовлення гній
праці фітнесу крима технічна
спеціальності і все показало здалося
овстуг на владну компанія вона
показала що ефективне використання
ресурсі ви сама за собою чорний
прогнання щоб geht es добував та яскравих
ну а на вигляд які з ну і ви не може і
примус цієї дати в записах
університеті я кай таке us with і треба
е тому що ви звучить і виберу і c
для нас шер що в х і на думку що
нам потрібно у регіонів
створе вати крупні цілі центри вище його
світи небагато маленьких регіональних
університеті а владність треба спиш
його tx помічниць за рахунок такого
укрупнення парять стем ми провели ревізію
розумів прийому 2016 уроку ворог вали в мережі
не дуриш снасті і
проблеми аки буду явним і у ступні та
кампанії 2016 руку для того, щоб з
актрис складень держави
у вийшла свиту змогла зростаєшся і
оплата брати давно йдуть дискусії про
оплату proteus vario свити ми малі різанини
закону дав норми палить т.к. їх
повністю навик він вдалося розум стем з
литва рахувати практику краєм євросоюзу
d середня зарплатня вас витян як пробула
на 10 22 сотки вище середні по
україні
у нас вона видна їжу тягу і це
середній там заплановано на 2017 рік
бідняк я
оплати про типи до логічних супротивників
евпатор і внесіть на два розряди
вже жорстка ви маєте рацію юний відповідь з
тому що в село б'є вище це
соціальний статус для нас
живу що через підняття мінімальні
зарубіж ні плати
зарплата us within just їжте більше не
шеннон савані 30 адже сотки рибалять цю
таблицю та для різних категорій вид по
видно і за втомитеся і зарубає на і плати
на мою думку csr стіни достатку терпимим
вуса muduma ти про реальність про модниць
бюджету не просто в минулому заявляти про
дієти щоб вона повернулася нас правді що
ж би джеки 2017 раку
стрибав проти неї бюджету до друга чита
її вже спину з парламентом і продовжу
цю дискусію з міністерством фінансів
вдалося abcd рахунку готових пивних
позитивних зі рушницею та фінансово неї
свити
загальних субвенції на зарплату за до
логічних супротивників
після першого читання з була передача
41 тіла сімдесятих мільярда за раз
і пояснювати 2 мільярди c дозволить пише
та середню зарплату в 440 увальнем
перевищення ременя мінімальної оплати
пройти середньому на 52 сотки
процом у треба розумі ти шоу та дотки
ранку та манілі гайд на міс собі бюджети
і я ж шувай наполегливо тривожний з поки
не допомогти йому всю практику у всіх над
хаджі них по всіх бюджетах місії ви хрум
пекло та організм свого самоуправління
самий для трьох заклади на дудакова
дотація 14 мільярдів про державне
бюджеті щоб я до чого такі
дістати не над хаджі не будуть злочинець
бідних романах ми могли стерилізувати
ідеальної системи освіти на місці
виділено об'єм же 170 мільйонів гривень
на біржан та замовлення на підготовку
кадрів у професій на технічних
початкових закладок за професією ми
загальна державного значення і сьогодні
то мови і ряд прийняти рішення
і бюджеті ж закладу ну ми змінюємо у
підходи до виплати стипендій студентам
ми перуки але ніщо не обходилося без у
цієї розмір стипендій
і добро доводить її воду аносова новому
законі про вищого світу прожити кованого
мінімуму починаючи з перевищень їх
стипендій з бачати на таблицю ми про
пуну їм щоб мінімально стипендія була
тисячу сто гривень максимально стипендія
на ремені прожити кому мінімуму для і
краш-тест студента в 1600 гривень для ти
хто навчається на технічних природний джо
математичних а так вже педа логічних
спеціальностях вид вищий на стипендію
1400 гривень тому що нам ваш кому ти
висновок зі студентів щоб навчилися самий
націк спеціально серце один заслуги в
такої мотивації і при цьому, що нам
потрібно і мислимо свірт оміст від до
парламенту зрадив проти вони та бюджету
до іншого чогось не сьогодні кішки на
стипендію розподіл світ соціальну та
академічну стипендію з таким чином
нібито може і бачатою top100
дві сили 9
дев'яносто сім мільярдів гривень
соціальної стипендії 2 мільярди
академічно нам необхідно перенести
соціальних в академічно одну силу
чотири десяті мільярди гривень то діви
можемо реалізувати підняти аст і по Індії
і в нас миску рот і з драматичною вухо
плані охолонути Індію
а особі стипендію від риму та палуби на
студень і в ті хі хі навчається найкраще
ми так само про пуну йому перейти вигляд
стипендії я до фарму волосатики
балон четвірка та вище 1 3 до
до рейтингові оцінки коли вищої
початковий заклад про крем своїм складом і
оцінювання може удаватися тій їжі критерій
наприклад жахливо укол їхня конференція
вищих inci п поза критерієм зад вірджині
в ціну і радую а ось жіночий студентами і
витку видно 50 адже сотки в nike rush їх
травня ранку йому водицю сходом далі все
для нас важливі його відразу милу що скільки
би не змішував з em up у абсолютних
числах фінансово не я у светрі нам
потрібно підходить і до моделі і витрати
кращого фінансово не я там ще сама
система вимагатиме і формування і тут ще
великий і підлога закону дали роботи в
нам прямо перед ей вид ранку.
закладі флікре сьогодні фактично
дмухається
доплати 100 будь я особливий окисні свити
Тиша філософія фінансово не я і наша
закону джабба поки не готова до неї
реалізації хочу так вже інформувати
і всіх злочинець що сидіння з видніше
субвенції про ікуя що й наговорила і
кобудо розбудив і на завдавши так вже на
доступний рік перед робляться вклади не
для прикраси бази
наших закладі в за хворий середні про
свити а сам і
300 мільйонів гривень знову ринку обсяг
даних територіальних
motto чоловік Іван з міліції геть та беруть на
себе краще зловить побачилися і самі
him 3 буду допоміг ти з автобусу ми з
обладнання mushkil 200 мільйонів гривень
на марення лазня шкільних автобусах нас
осад спи фінансово не з хутряними
бюджетами та 300 мільйонів гривень на
адже обладнання їх загальна
початкових закладі з підли плани колишні
мкр і рідних математичних предметів
і затятих закладі в кабінеті нафаня і
математики та фізики хімії біології
початковим та комп'ютерними класами для
нас на доступний рік його живим пріоритет
катастрофи і почервоніння ос
викладання природні ніж цієї
матричні його свити про науку статую 48
закону України про наукова наукова
технічно діянь з передачі та 1,75 вид
валового внутрішнього продукту України
реальний поки що знаки так і ми ніколи
небули
ios прошу глянути її києва на їй дихати
закриваючи падаючи вниз і направив їх їжджали
у 2016 у рот державного баз по середньо
фінансово не я болоті льке 16 сотки
ВВП і сьогодні
васей наш бюджет я шаную його поривчастих
доларовий equal еквіваленти буду 141
мільйон 413 тисяч доларів що зупинити
наука вийди джед таке маленьке країни
як латвія і від шиви дно що ціль ставить
нас за дружину серйозно чоловікові
виживання і тут наші дискусії в
середині уряду душа складні ми на мага
їм випарувало мати ситуацію і для нас
важливі б показати і новий механізм
фінансування за раз у нас проц його
витку видно аудит за євро в рамках
горизонту 2020 і в груди не буду навіть
серйозне складно дискусія з
результатах аудиту алим і бабу
недовго ст і умовно думка ще без свічки
заново фінансово не я ми не можемо ніби
конкурент нас про чоловіків його sieht їх
програмах якими по підписував і мишей
іконку ряд ніс про потужні я хочу по
видам це ще за зростання на даний момент
колими стала асоційованим членом
програми горизонт 2020 на відчуття
учасникам та стягни з 10 одного
міжнародного консорціуму приморської їх
немає шостки в бюджетах проектів пари вище
одинадцять із половиною мільйонів євро
при цьому наші особисті внесу до бюджету
програми
е5 ваги мільйонів євро топ то ми вже за
вийшов і практично вдвічі тесту
згуртувала отруту вниз від підлоги ви на позначку
шибут і power that is бюджет України там
у початий не показують usb ru ножиць
алое матеріально технічно база наших
Університеті в наука виросли джей
наших наукових установах
дружини витрем її тварини криті до цього
якщо нам важливі у всій конкурсі євро євро
тому нтц програми нато партнерство за
раді миру і бас пийте по 1 тис і зус або
ми за українець українського бюджету за
розгул up